owen good to see you good to see you so
as i understand
you went into this with not a whole lot
of knowledge of the mcu which at this
point in our timeline
is like just steeped in lore was there
some sort of
like who who took it upon themselves to
tell you about
all of it and are you now the biggest
fan well
kate the director uh in her sort of
you know our initial conversation she
gave a very
comprehensive um kind of overview of
what the series was going to be but
then it was when i got to atlanta and uh
meeting up with tom hiddleston and him
very patiently
uh kind of walking me through all of
just what you were saying the whole sort
of mythology and lore
of the mcu and specifically his
character because
my character is an expert on loki and
has really studied him so
uh that was really useful
did tom do his um impression of you
as loki for you he never did
um he uh i think he was
you know i think had i asked him to he's
such a polite person i'm sure he would
have uh
happily uh you know done it but um
he he never he never did
the big thing with loki is that you know
you can't trust him and that's
i'm sure that's that came up in all your
conversations so what is it
about him like why does mobius think
that he's the guy that
can work alongside him is it a thing
about being able to trust him or is it
certain one-upmanship well sometimes
there
you can trust not being able to trust
someone
and that can actually be a
um you know sort of a baseline
uh and with with loki that's certainly
the way that my character kind of
approaches him
is expecting him to um
you know be untrustworthy and
duplicitous but
having knowing all the facts that i know
i'm sort of um in some cases a couple
steps ahead of him just because i know
things about
his life that he doesn't even know and
so that gives me a little bit of power
going into any marvel project there are
fans that do know
like all that lore right like that over
decades worth of lore plus the
all the years before that with the comic
books are you going to pay attention at
all to any of the fans and their fan
theories because this happens with every
series where people go ah
there's this easter egg oh that's got to
be that character
yeah i i mean definitely it's a you know
i've become very aware of how passionate
the fan base is
um and it it's helped me to kind of
understand why we went to all these
measures to try to keep things secret
and uh and the look of the characters
and the story
plot ideas because people really want to
find out because there is so much
curiosity
all right thank you so much owen i'm
really enjoying the series can't wait to
see more
thank you all the best
you